uh and we the event starting and we're
live okay what's going on guys welcome
to this week's episode of a weekly poll
podcast bidding will be here in a second
I think there's anybody here right now
oh yeah it's been it's an instant like
we're just an free show into an empty
room right now we're thrown out or
evening enjoy here the people here
already oh oh my gosh yeah just I'm
surprised just don't sneak up on us like
that yeah scare the heck out of us if it
ain't changed but yeah like Ben he's
gonna be here in a second he was doing
his old pre-show thing he's a got a
preacher going on where he plays video
games and talked about comics on a
eligible monster on Twitch which you
guys walk we check out but our topic for
today what are the topics for today well
I will tell you exactly what the topics
are today they are right over here uh I
figured as is customary now for the show
we will run down the all new all
different marble number ones that we
read this week we all read different one
so I imagine this will be interesting I
know we kind of blew through a little
bit in the pre-show just in her regular
talking but we're gonna pretend like we
didn't do it uh then we got the
Fantastic Four taking off boxes release
schedule oh man never have I want to be
a morning zoo guy more and have that
sound effect of what we could do that we
could definitely bring that into the
show i'm at like it i think the demonoid
yeah they might be a little window it's
a little annoying but in a fun way and
then we got a CWS dc's legends of
tomorrow trailer that dropped today i
don't know if anyone else watched it
might just watched it before we started
cuz i figured it would be something we
would talk about already here to be
honest yeah no no it's no day cuz it
ended by being like a new the date that
it's coming out but like the CW universe
to me he's been very hit-or-miss like i
like flash flash is a fun show i think
it hits a lot of the right points green
arrow is my favorite superhero and arrow
is poison to my eye sockets every time i
watch it so I'm just like I know it's
bad because people want me to talk about
the CW shows and then like I hate all of
them like what you know the trick is you
get your buddy Joel to write you have it
owning you pass it off like your own is
what you do and then that i figured for
a last piece that we can close out on I
know we're all at different points of
watching it I still have two episodes
left myself will probably have a bigger
spoiler cast about it but we can give
initial thoughts and reflections on
jessica jones right yeah without
spoiling anything we want by the way we
should also point out to our huge DC
fans we're not deliberately withholding
DC information or it when DC as I think
fast put it perfectly when DC actually
put something out that is worth talking
about we will we will do this I mean
just and just because everyone's gonna
say it Batman Europa apparently not
worth talking about I haven't read it
really I got the hell out of it doing yo
it's it's gonna be sure it's gonna be
for good issues they're not wasting your
time with that when I appreciate it I
got that impression by the way we think
I'm in Europa that like it's a graphic
novel and they were likely yeah it's
like little like let's cut it up but
then that's the same impression I'm
getting with American alien and then I
had the same impression with all-star
Superman as well oh well off star
superman absolutely like morrison wrote
that like yeah no question he wrote it
like all on one thing with super and
american alien number one that first
issue was beautiful purchase it's
there's a huge like break up apparently
they're gonna be like no no like this
the second issue is gonna be totally if
an artist total different theme totally
stage and Clark's life um I can't wait
to c collected but i also just can't
wait for the next issue i don't know i
mean like I'm not the world's biggest
fan of max landis but he I feel like he
gets Superman I it's time you mentioned
max Lance I get the feeling a lot of the
geek community fell in love with Max
Landis then fell out of love with me I
think they love what he does and then he
comes on screen he's like hey guys
here's what I think and people like shut
the crack III think you're a little joke
I'll cos he's gonna bet on red letter
media please me red letter media I want
to be a lie brother man honey no that is
but we all go to admit literally amazing
okay okay I've gotta say we're not over
the screens outline right now nobody can
hear us a moment we're playing a
commercial on stream oh I just need to
say this faust you look like Legolas as
no one told you that yet I made that
joke laughs all this last
episode I got that joke i've also got a
few thousand comments saying exactly
that I've gotten blood elf which is why
they made me make my characters a blood
elf and well okay what else are awesome
oh whoops is amazing you got worry guys
I invited you all to the stream for my
gameplay not really and totally lying
but yeah we're like we were gonna sorta
530 we were like well you're in the
middle of playing your game so we just
went live on you team we said he'd join
up when you got a chance so you're alive
on YouTube right now uh-huh well alright
then oops I don't care what I sent you a
text I told you like we're starting in
five minutes well the show did freeze
huh I'll booth looks like if Rose nobody
throwing all this gold out no one can
hear us no one can make it yours I don't
know if they can't hear us looking at
the screen and it's not a hmm but um
yeah wait they can hear us yeah but
anyways so oh man so i think i minimized
the sched screen and i think that's
probably why it froze yes yes has a wart
on with everything what sounds by nicki
is that yeah Nikki by Nikki you never
heard of rats for nikki is a funicular
just might own now it's like fiddling ah
there you go there we go valleyhu other
fun diddly-dee girth a little but yeah
okay so some only well different marvel
so far right like I'm not the biggest
fan of like a majority of what they're
putting out yeah I'm liking a lot of it
but then again I was liking it before
before they renumber the whole thing and
had to basically like okay now we're
starting over kinda sorta not really you
had to read the stuff that came before
to really understand and not every book
is like that but I know I keep saying it
and I'm gonna keep saying it until like
we I see something but not nothing in
all new all different Marvel is all new
all different no oh really they feel
like the stories they would have told
anyway just without the renumber yeah
well you know it's interesting I got a
distinct impression and it just occurred
to me now we're forget for today's all
new all different marvel
I read a whole bunch of the titles and I
you know varying degrees of success or
at least opinions and and one of the
things I've noticed is I I feel like
even though there's some crossovers with
a lot of the characters it doesn't
really feel as cohesive as it used to
like this Marvel Universe feels a lot
more like divisive like it feels like if
you like this you're over here and you
like that you're over there but anyone
who's buying all the only all different
like Marvel and I monarch they're not
getting like a whole rich tapestry of
like this interconnected inner woven
Marvel Universe you're more getting like
a bunch of different stories that appeal
to a much different sensibilities
they've definitely cut it up into
fiefdom is now almost a little bit like
how DC does was like okay well you're
the Iron Man family and you're the Thor
family of books and you're the x-men and
inhuman family of books yeah and if
there is references to other characters
or other stories they're like it's
derisive you know like the humans like
do the X minus the humans Tony Stark's
like Peter Parker Peter Parker's like
like you know it's just yeah what's up
with that bed like Iron Man's got like a
stick up on him now about Peter and
everything like oh god if things keep
going bad by the end of the week him to
be working for Parker industries I think
he just hates competition i think is
your i guess like yeah what would be bad
about working for your friend dude your
friend who you liking you have been cool
ever less that's right let's lie p
ruined and that do fine I I had a point
and I've forgotten it someone else got
well alright so so like secret wars to
like we were talking about that one too
yeah not singapore's like number two
like secret wars like ddd long as well
secret wars as well yeah and like it
like fries well I like the first like
six pages with like Hickman where he's
like I don't have an ending and like I
don't know what we're gonna do here and
what was away look at me if you get
finished that's awesome like will
congratulate you and if you don't they
all work and I just in terms of this is
our selves from you and it does about
right that is a new vision children yeah
like I can't help relieve the like
that's how that meeting words it's the
literally worry about that later like
that book is literally all the jokes
we've been making on this podcast they
want to look down and turn them into a
comic it's kind of amazing and even at
the back of the book you're like hey and
be sure to pick up the finale
secret wars number eight dot dot dot
what do you mean it's not done what do
you think they had another issue with
not seriously not gonna be done till
December yeah yeah oh man I'm so ready
for sugar Wars to be done like the new
Secret Wars comes out tomorrow I think
like so many of the Chapmans in that I
was it really great I don't think it
does i think i looked at the
solicitations Dark Knight Returns three
comes out tomorrow it does I came hot
family you know all right here tonight
somebody asked about that and I talked
about that in comics at coffee and I
said look here's the deal Dark Knight
Returns was lightning in a bottle yes it
was like DC will probably never be able
to replicate that formula it was the
right thing chasing it yeah it was the
right story at the right time you know
it just it came out when they needed it
too and it changed and books I'm a comic
books darker but they're just like hey
like like we could do that again we can
know you can because one final is crazy
now and to me it's all the stories
you're doing there's nothing unique
about the dark knight returns oh no it's
true yes because and then that's what
made American aliens stand out so much
because it's not a dark comic it just
gave you all the warm fuzzies in my
video about it I actually said finally a
light comic everyone go by this just at
LDC that not all comics need to be dark
yeah some equal good it's true now it's
funny rub you mentioned because Frank
Miller is crazy and that is very much
true although ironically in an interview
he did just recently about him saying
I'm gonna be doing dark night for after
this he all but came out and said in
that issue I didn't write this brian
azzarello wrote this which is like what
what what the crap they wanted to put
his name on it is what it was they
really needed to put Miller's name on it
they needed it to come up with his
blessing cuz if it didn't come out with
Miller's name attached to it people
would have rioted and I would have just
said book did you read Dark Knight
strikes again yeah he don't eat anything
he's done in the last decade yeah
bidding are you gonna say something so
they're required uh what I'm fine I
think Benny's doing like an impression
of me yeah I care let me talk everybody
it's all good get a word
cutting bidding off Jesus but do I know
like it's uh you know I'm not hyped I'm
not on the high Trinity I like that man
like I like Batman stories I like sky
snyder's batman this I'm just gonna look
at me new release it's fine i read a
bunch of early reviews from outlets and
websites that shall remain nameless
because I don't to burn any bridges with
them or anything but it's a public
resources it was only three of the men I
think no after the free I don't steal
from each other it's a call it's
actually none of them act he was
actually another site and the phone
Newsarama look at chu com I wish man I
wish we got an early review no it's not
it starts with an i and ends with an end
was the website yet particular it was
hilarious reading their review because
you'll burn bridges what's that way i
don't know i think it's only three
letters starts with an i ends with an m
i think people combine what you came up
hurting bad ribs just give them money
and i'll be like joel is 10 out of 10
all the night of the game is the best
call do you thing of all time no honest
you know it really is but despite as i
was trying to say they do to review the
book of my loud yes oh nice i'm serious
i had a student I gamestop has Batman
lounge pants for fifteen dollars this
week I know what I'm you and I'm of the
most disappointed in Vinny at the moment
is the entire time that we were hanging
out in Rhode Island you never once wore
those pajama pants the guy would sleazy
guy would sleep in this cotton pickin
shorts or his underwear oh my god if you
work it i just bought these I normally
wear workout shorts up i'm hearing is
excuses right now says rob looks down
very disappointed i'm actually i'm
actually refill nice oh but I was trying
to say about Dark Knight Returns I had
to take my hat off to the person writing
the review for cuz they talked about the
comic in depth and yet never once
actually explained what the story was
about my fish is that a lot actually
let's say that takes a lot of restraint
I did see the near the New York Times
gave it a 10 out of 10 or nine point
eight out of ten just like wow okay who
paid you like okay like like
here's a really good example of what
they're doing like in Marvel if you guys
remember they said hey you remember how
like a Jew apocalypse was huge in the
1990s or like six months well it's like
let's revisit that and release a series
of stories tales from the age of
apocalypse and they all did terrible
because yeah no one cared it breaks
cares who cares and that's an embattled
like a really dark and sinister Batman
like we have that with shot snyder's
batman really only thing the problem
with this whole thing is it's not like
the dark knight returns universe is a
rich well that needs to be tapped oh but
they're trying to make it into a
universe because it's not just this
story it's this story and a series of
tie-ins to go along with it of course it
I don't like dark knight returns I think
a [ __ ] I think Frank Miller's act so
whatever this in everyone acts out of
character it's like reading and justice
before they decided to actually turn it
into a story justice is great but
they're all out of character but but in
the dark knight returns they're really
out of character like to the you say it
is all babia superman wonder woman
[ __ ] green arrow they all don't add
in garlic on top what's easy three have
you not seen the artwork yeah I've seen
the artwork but I don't I would not tell
at all the whole entire thing is just
I'm gonna just gonna have them fight I
don't like it I will admit I'm not the
biggest fan of The Dark Knight Returns I
won't say I hate it I won't say but I
never go out on my way to read it just
because when i read Batman I don't want
to read a military [ __ ] book and
that's what it is yeah and it's a but I
love I don't like anything Frank Miller
does cuz i think the guys is all about
hahaha comic books from the 90s oh yeah
all about dudes look at what i do to the
women are prostitutes man loves him snot
fasta toots oh yeah and everyone the
back he looks like he's Freddy Krueger
I'm gonna throw it out there oh it looks
pretty good I would not agree with a
very throwing the gauntlet down all over
the place I don't like basically I think
you look like a great for getting
stories from Freddy Krueger that's what
we're getting and that's just makes it
even worse for me so when you go to
sleep tonight and Frank Miller is in
your dream
he's trying to pull you out Celebi known
people when you call me the judgmental
one remember that cop Benny outright
judged Frank Miller's then based on the
fact that looks like Freddy Krueger yeah
exactly and it's a perfectly viable
reason to judge somebody for looking
like an evil villain I can see Sal
trying to choke it down right here cuz
she's like ah the Gospels man you know
the best possible actually it's just one
just that one you have a come on the
exact same argument is anybody that
looks at a Muslim it goes terrorist I
look at Frank Miller and go Freddy
Krueger what you see no that's let's see
that's this you know hey that's what I
like about it is is this literally has
DC even said why they're making the dark
night 3i miss Melanie bout to balance
the way to get wala to show you what
comes out of that I guess man I mean I
wouldn't am NOT gonna it's not like it's
time like it here's the problem dark net
returns isn't like a formula that you
can just apply to different things nor
is it like well now it's time for Dark
Knight to come back because bled like
it's just a story that works really well
it's about it's a product of its time
it's why the sequel is work because it
wasn't about like the sequel wasn't
about anything and then Miller like
right at the end was like 911 happened
asked me about 911 and then turn it into
something else and when you have no
direction we have no theme and you have
no point like there's no there's no
substance it doesn't mean anything it's
just at the end of the day you have to
judge by a story and even when Dark
Knight Returns being a byproduct of like
comics number one being changed number
two the Reagan era you know all that
even if you break all that away you did
you root that's why it's timeless
because when you take it out of that
time period you can still read and be
like this a cool story is just straight
up just a good story um believers erk
and it's Billy berserk and and it
doesn't ship and back matter isn't this
is this is the exact reason I can tell
you that this entire thing is your money
and it's almost at writing is on the
wall they're bringing back bat all-star
batman and robin yeah yeah it the fact
that they're just bringing back Frank
Miller for anything that has ever been
discussed by him yeah tells you like
he's not coming back to go Frank
Miller's bringing you a new Batman story
no you know it's not it's not it's not
you know Frank Miller's coming back to
tell you a story about Superman Frank
Miller's coming down
to revitalize the Green Lantern
franchisor tell you the story of the
flash it's dark net is cut he's coming
back to write Dark Knight free it is
possibly going to do all-star batman
their name dropping heavy titles to just
get money well in all-star batman is
justice just a prequel to dark knight
anyway it's all part of his ridiculous
what self it is established universe
which is whatever is it his self insert
universe to which you opined on in your
own to which I quite like that theory
that all of Frank Miller's Batman books
are actually about Frank Miller himself
there semi-autobiographical yeah we all
900 well that's that's a problem is that
i think is the issue with light miller
he's not a terrible writer the problem
is like if imma be honestly he got lucky
a couple times what I did break Mel is
just from an old age that's the problem
he wrote he wrote like he from a differ
by elahi revitalized daredevil and he
was some really good daredevil stuff and
then he made like the DIA the dark
knight he had the watchmen he had 300
and it was like those things do sin city
is also cool since it's cool but it's
but it's like a relaxing well this guy
can make anything and be Jesus and
everything that he does because here I
handful of good stories and that's what
the problem is because it's just like
Stanley Stanley is a good example
Stanley wrote some great stories has
anybody here read anything recently that
he had his hand in because he has
written [ __ ] he has been writing a lot
of stuff hey no one has read it because
Stanley wrote good stories created good
characters but it's all I much better
when Frank Miller wrote The Dark Knight
Returns in dark knight they were good
for their time but I personally don't
think they they hold up to the stew time
they don't I don't do great animated
movies well these why don't either well
the Dark Knight does because like that
they don't not like shifted comics like
husbands were audience yeah they were
like you know light-hearted and stuff
you know and like yeah the death of when
Stacy which is kind of okay I mean
things it was the dark knight returns
and it was like okay suddenly we can go
into darker territory now and and that's
that was a sim like the importance of
that story at the time but the issue now
is everything's dark you crack open any
comic book and you're probably going to
find and
story arc people are going to die yeah
well that's the problem is is just
because it's a game-changer doesn't make
it timeless it was a game changer it
changed everything around there but that
doesn't make it a timeless thing no that
doesn't make it time was the fact that
it is makes a time and it it is directly
translatable you could pretty much set
that book in any time it's like
Shakespeare like I'm not saying that
it's as good as the tempest but I'm
saying that like as far as comic books
go dark knight returns is timeless Dark
Knight Returns informs everything it
does look at the freaking variant the
torrent of variance we got from artists
and just like they were just literally
given a directive draw me your favorite
moment from Dark Knight from the from
both books from both books and the only
drew dark knight returns and they each
image that they pursue while some of
them are like some of them they faked it
where they were like I want to draw a
Dark Knight Returns Batman with Wonder
Woman and I guess I'm technically doing
the sequel but really I'm not
referencing anything from it like every
moment they did they depict is a classic
epic moment from that comic I mean that
makes it timeless wanting the
timelessness about it because Batman
fighting Superman's happened a thousand
times now and that was an awesome best
protector I am gonna be honest it wasn't
like a sudden change that comics
suddenly got duck because of Dark Knight
Returns alan moore was writing swamp
thing at least two years before that or
that you you got all kinds of like okay
like I wanna hear I wanna hear an answer
to minute that was a good question i
want to hear an answer to binny's
question like what makes the Dark Knight
Returns timeless the fact that it
inspired a whole generation that people
keep coming back to that story that it
clearly sparks something in them well
really there's never a harmless one of
them is because it is still in print
today and people still read it today
with no context from where it came from
and still derived the exact same joy in
the end enjoy and / uh celebrate the
exact same points that everyone always
enjoys and celebrates throughout time no
but what what is the point is what I'm
saying cuz whenever I talk to someone
who who's not in the know is the dark
never turns you go dark net returns have
you read it it's on your must-read list
and the answer is either yes or no and
if they did the only thing they ever say
is well yeah Batman foster
permit that's not what makes that that's
I'll be honest that's literally the last
thing anyone I've ever given that book
too and I've given the book to dozens of
people so what are they saying though
that's what I'm asking like what is just
ok they basically especially for non
comic readers they say that this story
makes them like Batman or makes them
understand the character better or it
tells them a story that they've never
heard before while we read comics and
we've seen Batman fight Superman a
thousand times even though he's under
the control of poison ivy or something
I'm gladly remember that was that a hot
one like they Gimli drew it and they
were like look it's look this is it and
it's like no it's not it but whatever
but the point being like yes we've seen
or at least we've imagined Batman vs
Superman a million times that's number
one not even the first time we've seen
it and number two it's it's just an
element it just a it's just a byproduct
of the story you know uh the images that
we see it's not just that fight but also
just the way that that fight is
presented you know that's why i don't
really like the movies version of the
fight because the movie from the movie
version of a fight make super makes
batman into a superhuman like he wears
an Augmented suit because you got to
wear a suit when you're fighting
Superman because otherwise you'll die
but Superman is clearly holding back in
that entire fight because he's like I
don't care if you're wearing a suit I
could still kill you but I'm your friend
like Superman is deliberately holding
back so he doesn't hurt this person that
he still views as his friend they have
to completely conflicting ideologies so
the battle isn't really about them
fighting each other about them like
breaking bones it's about them trying to
it's about Batman trying to get under
his skin so Superman not understanding
Batman's methods and Batman literally
putting himself out there putting
himself on a cross to get Superman to
understand it and at the end of the book
when Superman winks at Carrie Kelly when
Superman carries going to dig him back
up that's Superman understanding the
lesson the Batman he laid out for him in
that fight that fight is meaningless and
then I will admit like from my
perspective of someone that doesn't
really paid much attention to that
member because they don't really enjoy
the character by enjoy his extended
family all the time I loved the
character Carrie Kelly I thought her
reaction to when she killed someone was
so realistic I was capable oh I killed
someone you go like you
would throw up he would stop crying cuz
you've killed someone [ __ ] did you know
that Carrie Kelly was it was really
gonna be a kid it was gonna be a boy and
one of Frank's peers said this is a
unique opportunity you should make it a
girl and Frank's like all right like it
was literally an afterthought oh wow
yeah I guess I'd anyway I mean like and
look the fact is if you don't like it or
if you think that it's like cemented in
its time I mean look Reagan's in the
book yeah but don't know that make you
like presidents the is it's I take dark
knight returns and I put it into the
same period same tier as the timeless
comics that is on everyone's must-read
list and no one reads it but everyone
likes to reference it all the fake comic
readers like to be like dark knight
returns Killing Joke will have you read
them no but battles by Joker and this
one a batman fight Superman over here
you're like that like that's why should
I completely agree with you i would call
out anyone who did that but what I'm
saying is and that's why I don't feel
dark number turns is actually like time
at comics in general are difficult to
make timeless because there's so many of
them sound like a book where you have
one book this is it a bad man book comes
out every three years and we can pick
them out there's a new story every six
months second we don't years worth of
material right yeah and that's the
problem with comics where the whole
argument of what really makes a timeless
story really valid people yeah just
whether or not it's a good story or it's
great for its time or it changed the
face of comic books that doesn't matter
that that's where to notate it as but to
make it a must read a timeless read it's
very difficult when the stuff that
happened at Dark Knight has nothing to
do with comics and today it barely had
anything to do with comics back then we
had the sequel that was great now we're
going to get dark knight 3 that's gonna
be like where are you going with the
story at this point well the fact the
fact that Dark Knight 3 is irrelevant
doesn't invalidate dark knight returns
it doesn't make it not ties because I
mean like in the end if you don't agree
I I would like to know what is a
timeless comic in your eyes well another
thing a time was comic to to an extent I
don't even know if you're the game list
I say to an extent I don't think they
exist I don't because the problem is
everything changes so much if you want
if you want to have I think that what
makes any comic what makes it timeless
comic
is when the is is is literally that is
the ever changing nature of comics the
fact that everything literally I can't
even really get into the OL noodle
different Marvel because it's been well
established that they're just gonna
change it again and again and again and
again and there's and and the things
that happened you know you can't be like
oh man vision is family it's like the
only won't in six months or a year or
two or you know spider-man as it has a
company it's like well he won't in a
year or two and one time for the new
movie right like they're gonna change it
whether it's because a corporate reasons
or because of personal like changing in
the guard and the creative team but in
spite of that there are stories that
exists that happened even as a byproduct
of that you know like like the died
Wednesday she died like oh this is just
Jerry Conway Stanley telling a story
about how his girlfriend died people
still go back to because it that these
are the stories that are inflexible dr.
Gwen Stacy is a great example of what I
think is one of the worst examples of a
timeless comic because the Gwen Stacy
thing was not intentional it wasn't at
least Dark Knight was aiming for
something he was trying to tell a story
the Gwen station was oh let's just kill
a girl off and see what happens that's
right that's right buddy but in spite of
that despite that it becomes timeless
because it hits on a theme or it hits on
an identity that like comic books either
represent or that we as readers
gravitate towards its reason why not all
set out to write a timeless story time
with hell exactly half right Millie I'd
like a Roman what Frank Miller succeeds
with dark no returns is because he was
just writing a cool comic at this I
don't think he was yeah I mean there's
only one way to write a truly timeless
story and that is to just have it set
outside of time just have it set in a
time period or in a world that just
can't exist well it's why dark net
returns works cuz it's outside of
continuity well the way I look at the
timeless comics and this is where my
argument comes in with this whole thing
is most of the time the timeless comics
like Dark Knight Returns Dark Knight
killing joke they just keep bringing up
killing Joe because it's the first one
that comes to mind whenever someone says
a timeless border when using yeah right
but gwen stacy is there not so much
timeless as when you read them when they
came out it was amazing for those people
so like dark night was great when i read
it back in the day it was great for you
when you read it back in the day
but the thing is and this is why I did I
argue about the whole idea of a timeless
book there are so many books that come
out even though it's on everyone's top
rebe list I don't know any new comic
readers that have actually read those
books anyone in the last five years that
is coming out of the way to read those
books it's the exact same argument when
it comes to like video games because Rob
and I had a debate about this other
night we were playing black ops 3 and
rob was saying how the greatest the
greatest call of duty was modern warfare
one that was his argue that was like
well no no in here and while I don't
discount how good modern warfare one was
it's the in that same exact argument is
timeless for the individual who read it
at the time and what it meant to the
person itself that doesn't make the game
or the comic an actual timeless thing
that everyone in the world must read it
like Dark Knight is not a work of
Shakespeare that will teach you like the
Falla T of man and stuff like that but
what itself I'll teach you a fallacy of
Batman is it exactly what I say what I
was saying is like it's it's timeless to
the individuals who read it for their
various reasons like for you Dark Knight
represents a lot more than it represents
to me air or to eat Faust and that's
what makes it timeless to you yes and
then I think that I think that
timelessness is in the eye of the
beholder and while I agree for certain
titles there are others that can be
argued no in fact dark net returns
all-star superman some people would
argue is also another like timeless
story yeah I will admit like that are
genuinely timeless comics out there but
I think the majority of them just have
not been read by the masses because what
makes a comic timeless isn't necessarily
popularity it's the message in the
stylization of the story like miracle
man like Marvel man / miracle man is a
timeless comic even though most people
haven't read it my horsey has a great
example of what is always portrayed as a
timeless comics and man's like everyone
do Sandman Sandman another one which is
by the way very cemented in its time
death is the 80s goth chick like
everything about Sandman is 1985 the
best example of a timeless comic that I
can think of is flex montelibano muscle
mystery because issue represents the
stage of comics through time they also
represent a stage of your life and no
matter what people are going to grow up
and that history of comics is always
there and that's what makes it timeless
seriously here school's out for summer
every year when school is actually out
he wrote a timeless song because it
captures a shared experience between
music I will say is timeless because in
the argument with music is and there in
its forced timelessness because the
radio station will play schools outright
summer every year the school's out you
will hear it every year you know that's
what makes a timeless song but that
doesn't happen with comics you don't
walk into a comic store and dark knight
is sitting right here a must read it is
barrier in that wrong free comic book
store I've ever been in has a dark
knight returns poster or a display or
it's out there why don't they head out
on the back wall I'm going in the back I
don't read a single comic book store
I've ever been in in my life and I've
been in over a hundred comic book stores
but then that doesn't matter if it's at
the front on displayed in advertise
because popularity and advertising does
not make a [ __ ] timeless comment like
it but I am saying that it is now in the
fact is you can't say like back in the
day was time back in the day you think
it's timeless because like we read it
back that neither of us read it in 1986
okay and me and everyone who's read it
since then has read it years after it
came out and they're having the same
shared experience that's bike by by this
argument I will go ahead and say
spider-man to the movie is timeless
because it is guess it runs because
constantly brought up at such a classic
movie even though like and not even just
you i know a lot of people that dislike
that movie to an extreme i think like
it's done by today's standards but the
movie is it bullet because it uses
thematic elements from like Joseph
Campbell's book like it's clearly just
like the it's number one spider-man's
origin is timeless so if you're gonna do
it right if you do it right then your
story will be everyone has done that
origin okay i'll give you like like for
me okay for me like timeless colleagues
are not defined by how well they sail
how will i wish there i'm just saying
like I back when the time was coming by
like the impact of the comic in terms of
the world of comics like here's an
example Days of Future past where i
consider Days of Future past to be a
timeless comic because in the end no
matter what X mins
story arc you have there's always the
lingering concept that somewhere along
the line something could happen that
could make that reality come true right
and it's not yes god loves man kills is
a little more time was a godless man
kills is good but in terms of like the
x-men scenario like the x-men continuity
the x-men universe like that future is
always there like that could always
become the future and so like to me that
is a timeless comic because at any point
that comic could become reality that
kind of duck comic could become the
Marvel Universe any games the very state
of the enchanting everybody goes in the
back of your mom x-men are almost all
dead now you have like most of us
earthbound superheroes are dead signals
come back I mean the whole nine yards
like that can always happen well what's
cool about it is it is also kind of
outside continuity like you don't have
to know anything about what's happening
in x-men today we're back then it kind
you do a little bit but to them for the
most part that's for me like the mark of
a time as comic as a comic that's that's
outside continuity or at least so much
though that you can literally read it at
any point and you still get either the
core the character you get the story or
you get the theme without having any
without having anything but the context
within the pages so we so basically what
we've now established is everyone's view
of a timeless comic is completely
different problem whether it be a
popularity thing whether it be something
that changes comics because by rob's
view of timeless just brand new day is a
timeless comic even though I think
everyone here could argue be happy we
have argued I don't think that's true
because it sank by his view I'm not
saying it is but I'm saying if it
changes the fascia comes that changed
spider-man or changes the face of
someone else of a group or a person's
interpretation of comics or their view
of comics in general like I mean Final
Crisis is a great it would be considered
atomos comical also certainly want you
to believe that no but look around
consider fun why I can at all is coming
because they didn't it wasn't so
impactful I mean it was a continuity
reboot and like like sounds like a
dangerous he hated one more page 3 we're
talking about brand new day yeah well
guess I'll had a brand-new day brand-new
day him one more day what everyone call
it man the same thing that same thing
like like I'm hated because
you know like will sound hated because
the reason why it was written less so
than like the content in the story
itself right the story isn't so bad
until you get until it falls apart but
like it isn't so bad until it is this
like the idea of spider-man like let's
let's say a man who is exploring the the
the you know the duality of his life
like [ __ ] EP share the woman that he
then raised him or the woman that he's
gonna spend the rest of his life with
and like the byproduct of one decision
literally guiding him through that story
like it's very fast Ian like it feels
like a like a story that you know can be
timeless um unfortunately the Tigris and
it's just is a strained if not you know
it's not as good as it could have been
and whatever but like it change the
character that I love so it's a it's
transformative but not all the
transformation is good it's not maybe
why was doing what I was getting at with
for job Rob jumped into that is
basically timelessness is is entirely
subjective her for me I just like dark
knight word arc night I wouldn't
recommend it to any Batman fans but it
depends on what Batman you're looking
for you love dark knight I mean if you
want to do a spider-man thing I would
say don't avoid Clone Saga but for some
people some people they actually liked
the clothes you love it more than they
love what's happening now ya know agreed
I thought me but okays that clone sog is
timeless I don't know about that and uni
or maneuver that it wasn't that it was
that it was insightful or in helping the
wattage on characters and she just the
concept of the clone like in general God
had brought us Cain brought us um James
I've learned inspire and spiders under
general hood the test of time yes oh I
think I think the point here is you
could name any story and at least one of
the five of us could argue that it's
timeless because we all have different
points of view and what to being
timeless is no okay like here's a good
example of a standalone continuity
timeless story would be like Infinity
Gauntlet like you literally have a
scenario where a guy gets infinity gems
wiped out half a life in the universe
and it is that like it creates this
great big huge cosmic theatre worse
literally like if we don't stop this guy
like everything is going to end let's
it's like you don't need to read
anything else like all the faces are
recognized
you know they even tell who they are in
case you don't know like you know it's
nearly a standalone story and says that
I would say is like a a timeless classic
that anybody could pick up and read and
given what's coming out in the next
several years I'd say a lot of people
look at me picking up a reading it no
dad but they're definitely going to be
like what the hell like the writing is
gonna they're gonna be like what you
know about it's just be written back
then everyone I'm not saying the
Stalin's writing during infiniti call it
was the greatest writing ever identical
twins what is running is now yeah like I
when I read in Revelation when they came
out and I was like man sterling what do
you this is the same thing yeah and if
you like that you know what I would be
interested to see if we each come up
with a video or just a list when she
here for next week and we each come up
with our top 10 books that if someone
actually came to us and we wanted to
recommend what they would be just to see
the differences oh no all of our country
I'd be like number one the century
limited series I would love is like all
of us in our top ten recommendations to
new route was a fine and we should
discuss that next week because obviously
all five of us have different views yeah
then we be collected volumes or like can
that be whole runs because like I think
Punisher max is a timeless Roger
whatever whatever whatever you order
like this next week we'll all sit down
and what do you if someone came to you
on the street right now said I got two
minutes give me the top 10 things to go
by right now okay can we do top five cuz
like that stuff today I five-week a
[ __ ] cuz cuz I I know it's gonna happen
no one will do it in till three o'clock
next week that our pocket oh god I'm
supposed to make a list uh well yeah
like you wobble periscope it later like
in about an hour or so but no one gets
my less what do you all think I mean
that is like that is something like it
that is a good point like well that is a
good point because a case I was making
with with you know mano wafer with that
game is like if that was a first game
you picked up people were just like
obviously disagree to skimmer that's how
it always works like it's all games cars
only did I ever played yeah it'll always
be your like that is the best one well
just lay just like zelda ocarina of time
everyone's always the greatest game ever
have you tried to play that on n64
recently cuz i'll tell you right now
that is not doable rigan water temple
know you played on the DS bro yeah I did
the mercy but what I'm saying is it's
all about nostalgia and that's where a
lot of the timelessness comes out of its
the nostalgia and then it's like handed
on and on and on people go watch the
economy pop and rock solid be like go
read Dark Knight everyone's gonna go
pick up Dark Knight based on that but if
you know if everyone across the board is
like Dark Knight sucks even though it
was game-changing and everyone followed
along with it it wouldn't be as timeless
anymore it all comes down to what people
think and what your recommendations are
like I guess there's a reason that like
in school they make you read the romeo
and juliets in the Merchant of Venice is
and you know the like ablation merits
thank you there's enough fun yeah and
that's I mean those doesn't really you
know like the death of superman ii is is
a good example of a non timeless
colleague but what is likely the concept
of the death of superman was a
culturally significant decimo yeah yeah
but it wasn't our yep it was but the
book itself was not time you could argue
about the death of superman all you want
because it changed a lot of things I
mean it really did it changed the face
of comics it changed how they're gonna
handle things like that it said we can
kill big guys it's going to happen it
will bring them back your later after a
convoluted plot but then the gold on
punched into space yeah but I really
think the guys blow up Green Lantern
city yeah never go away like no it
really won't ever every other issue Hal
Jordans like Co city yeah well then that
goes into something like some people
pointing out to me in the chat like some
a few people said oh is one of the first
top ten most timeless comics gonna be
the Teen Titans and I'm going to say no
because i love the Teen Titans but the
point of that book is days of its time
it's so ground into the years that it
was released in so late and just because
something isn't timeless doesn't mean
its lesser it just moves through it's
finished I'm like in that natural my
argument comes into because I find
things that are timeless to be less time
was in more just a lot of people's
recommendations yeah I will say go read
dark net because as much as I just I
mean I would not put it on my top
recommendation I do feel because of the
amount of people that enjoy that book
and how much it did change every
greater once you start crossing that
bridge from casual I pick up a couple
comics to going out and getting full
trades and look at classes everyone
should read it because it's one of those
things you need your own opinion on you
can't listen in but you can't listen to
South you need to read it and see if you
get anything out of it yeah but and
that's what I was like is it much as I
know Benny could tell you the story you
need to read it because there is like a
whole visual language going from the
comic is literally visual and ya know in
what I would go what I would actually
argue about dark knight or Achilles or
any of these things is the only reason
you need to read it is because it's
considered timeless it's on everyone's
recommendation if it wasn't everyone's
recommendation I would not have
recommended it it's just simple as that
and you know because you want to be
informed to by the time they make the
movie so you can be much cool guy in the
movie fan but you know the comic well
because even in even with like movies
and stuff like that you know oh they're
gonna read like everyone is argued about
Fantastic Four and how bad it was it was
gonna be like we without even seeing it
go watch the originals you have nothing
to compare it to how are you comparing
it to nothing other than general movies
when you could go watch all the ones
then you can be like this is how bad
things could be you have people that go
out there and they're like manna still
is the worst movie I've ever seen okay
did you watch superman returns did you
go watch the classic superhero movies
back in the day when we had Captain
America hitch Hood stealing a car if you
enjoy yes like when you compare current
movies to that they're great like but
like that's why I enjoy them because we
are going in the right direction but
like I said that's why you need any all
the recommendations you need to watch so
you have something to compare it to yeah
whatever moving plane about like comic
book films these days I'm like go back
and watch like Dolph Lundgren's the
punish yeah I don't say basically
Colossus great i will say just because
something's bad now doesn't mean the
things that back then were any less bad
or any more bad something is bad is bad
let's sometimes a lot of hours direction
i I end up running into a lot of people
who want to be the indie book reader
they're like oh I don't touch marble and
I don't touch GC I don't like those
particular what the way they tell their
stories but i'll read invincible you
know already the indie line of superhero
stuff and I'm like well why don't you
like Marvel and DC and like well cuz
they're popular that's not a reason to
dislike something have you
do you have openly admits that that's
why but we all know that's the reason I
did this person in particular did they
then comb their mustache and pick up
their skinny jean what I'm here's the
real question is how many how many how
many shots of espresso in their latte do
they get but that and it's an argument I
had with quite a few people like you
can't say you don't like something if
you actually have experienced it I read
every book so that I can look at you and
go I don't like this here's why you know
what is super boring like when I was all
red like I know through figure was just
like hey this is this is really cool
like Hickman and like he's talking dr.
doom and everything and then I'm sort of
reading the rest was like well the rest
of this stupid it's yeah they had five
good pages and then they filled it up
with stuff they had left earlier is it I
mean that's I mean that's tougher nut to
crack oh god yeah I mean that's why I'm
still reading secret wars because as
much as I hate it and I really do hate
it I want to have a solid opinion on it
cuz everyone else is like oh my god this
is the best thing ever and I'm just like
I don't get it exactly what you're a
good I thought secret war started out
strong I have no idea with the plant
where they plan to go into this I feel
like at this point like Hickman's just
like a secret wars 2 is a great when i
read that I'm like I think this is what
happened because yes we're it literate
likely you said earlier because I jumped
in when you're talking about it I think
that's what happened cuz reading secret
war since like I'd say issue 6 it really
feels like things are just getting
thrown at a wall while he figures out
what the hell he wants to do with this
ya know dad but you said she was nothing
but setting up the actual war and that
made me realize we're now on issue 8 of
a war that hasn't happened it was
supposedly to petaluma tissue I'm
worried that that was the war I think it
was as if you remember that was supposed
to be the penultimate issue I think the
next one's gonna be the big revelation
and then nine is just gonna be putting
everything back together now ya know in
the final issue in the last panel it's
like so wait where was the war and it's
just like it's a secret but yeah I would
be something to that ever really some
comic where they skipped the action like
they got into it and then they jumps to
the end and only what is this is that
any Scarl go comic ever yeah man who
christmas special like you defeated Fei
knows what does she do
she just did don't worry about but all I
can tell you is using my watcher powers
it was definitively the 616 version of a
no it is not a clone hologram or mind
control situation it was the real fan
oohs and you really destroyed her with
tippy toe that's stupid screw-up but I
mean like I said like and this exact
reason why I still read the battle
worlds so I can tell you all but three
of them are [ __ ] I didn't like a new
word about the tie-ins you know because
I'm what do you think of them but I
didn't finish reading a lot of them i
finished my athol or cuz Thor's actually
important to what's happening in the
main Thor story I tell you I tell like a
force in carroll core I'll see I likes
Michaelson x-men 98 and a force is
getting a book so you know it was good
is the third what I like for those
wondering is where the monsters dwell
but I had nothing to do with anything
italics just a holla Vanya garth ennis
for this writing us to a garden yeah I
just love it I love letting him do his
thing that's what they did he got to
write about war and pilots which are you
know he's two favorite fetishes that you
got sold and everyone in it's an [ __ ]
like yeah I know exactly which means it
was awesome whatever was like should I
read that one I'm like well yeah but is
kayla has nothing to do with anything
there's no but none of it have anything
to do with anything anyway yeah that's
true I love they got him back and that
was the project he did and then didn't
DC get him back to you to do like a
section-8 thing tour is okay I'm gonna
do another weird comic oh dude i hate
section 8 it is the most garbage book
I've ever read like it's it's nothing
but making fun of like mentally
handicapped people maybe the old hit
man's oh well end's yeah the old hit
man's cuz that's what section 8 spins
out of hitman which was a series that NS
a-- did previously for DC which was like
it no idea was from just I know all bail
it was making fun of everything like yet
been complaining cuz he's getting a
parking ticket so that they can then ask
him to join the the mentally handicapped
squaddies built like really what it is
that's enison and nutshell NS has always
been incredibly tasteless and a lot of
the times it worse because he's writing
Punisher cuz you know it's supposed to
be tasteless no I agree it is and I do
like his writing I mean I even read I've
even read crossed until they just they
went away from actual story just said
how many times can make somebody naked
and cut their own penis off
more times that you would think I don't
was reading preacher like I was I was
like man like I really want to do a
video on preacher because they're doing
the show for preacher and I might I'm
gonna make a video on it when it
launches ma'am a preacher is like like
if you have like if you have any
religious convictions that book is going
to piss you off Oh what's going to big
time there and I was I will also say by
the way I think preacher is a timeless
comic as well i was gonna say there's
another one widely considered to be a
time I when I regretted app forever i
will admit to this with preacher i have
not read it that's i can't even have
anything to really dig it here's the
entire premise a preacher all right like
an angel and a demon bang they have a
kid God runs off in fear and this dude
creature literally travels around it
with like his friends and and it's like
I mean it's it it's probably the most
likes a girl just booked a time ever oh
yeah I and the baby terrifies everyone
though because the baby is this new idea
not of heaven or hell and everyone is
absolutely losing their minds over the
whole thing it's just it's just a
Western Wizard of Oz yeah with religious
overtones there's an irish vampire and
that's fun it's garden there's your
venom and garth ennis isn't it he plays
cassidy the vampire he wrote himself
into the book and it's great yeah well i
will say the killer Saints like the
Patriot killers killers amazing singer
killer that's what is you have the
patron say to feel like he's cool like
school his material told a look he's so
cool that Jimmy Palmiotti made
references to him in his jonah hex
series actually yes he did Oh near the
end he started making references to
jonah hex and the saint of killers but
gamma gamma mine o mine Jimmy Buffett
wait wait wait what is that what from
where it was from the dependable yeah
with the tail end of all-star western he
started making references to preacher in
jonak stories hmm there's over there
Zachary there's an overt there's like an
unsubtle reference to preacher also in y
the last man York has an F communism
lighter why the last one really cool but
I gave up reading like try to play catch
up on that that's too many to say it did
not hold my interest and I love Branca
yeah and that's just it I I got like
four trades into it I'm like I got one
trade and I'm like nah
I can't wait until they turn scalped
into a TV show like the key threat to do
and then it'll be Joel's time to shine
about his love of Jason Aaron noir
stores like let me tell y'all about
scalp man you see it's about Dashiell
bad horse and you see oh god I can't
wait until the Teen Titans TV show comes
out cuz my addy library is gonna do well
it's there that they're doing it they're
doing it they're ready yeah yeah
threatening I think Robin won't be in it
no it's already in production
Nightwing's gonna be in our Oracle Hawk
and Dove and some others they don't care
about you guys for nuns just hey I y de
here's my question are they willing to
link it to the flare overs cuz Supergirl
is like doing this whole I don't know
but if Nightwing's in it I don't know
who I like that what does that mean like
there's Batman somewhere yeah I think it
might not they're probably gonna do it
like that it was Superman a Supergirl
where it's like look at his boot now
he's texting her actually that's a
perfect segue cuz one of the pieces and
news i had on here i'm not sure of
anyone solder upon the only one the DC
legends of tomorrow trailer hit today I
did not watch the trailer it's it's cool
it's a time travel story of this sooner
than you would think actually I thought
I'd worry but I think it's coming out
sooner isn't it I want to say Jane I
think you're right on january so not not
that way it's a time travel story rip
hunter picks up a bunch of the also
Ran's from the CW universe so Adam and
white canary because they messed up her
story and Captain cold and heat wave cuz
people like them as villains so the
likely miss heroes too and we traveled
like they travel back to Vietnam era and
it's all to stop Vandal Savage before he
can Days of Future past the world yeah
well that's cool so the first trailer
that like that like comic con trailer
and I was like but but here's the thing
though like here's the mind-blowing
thing that people are freaking out about
in the trailer Vandal Savage says you
know in my time I've seen amazing things
I've seen you know menaced you know I've
seen Dark Knight's die in men of steel
fall oh oh so so now they're dropping
reference and also there's a bit to
where heat wave and Captain Cold are
stealing this green emerald and it says
right on there emerald but I'm like is
that kryptonite are they steal all you
got it's funny cuz now you mention that
they've never made reference to them
they stole their storylines
but they've never never but they don't
your own references I'm waiting for how
many for like Hal Jordan to show up yeah
in arrow like a children do they been
hinting ahead and constantly and I'm we
do they made they they went with like
constructs yeah they may be sure to make
sure that they made sure that you knew
dr. lights power was hard or like you
could have named that anything and then
you know like we've discovered you can
even take light and you can make it into
hard like constructs sounds like well
there it is but you really want Greg
Berlanti to take a second stab at Green
Lantern after what he did the first time
with the property look look at least he
knows now just don't do that it's really
hard to get people who make stuff like
that to not do it again like joel
schumacher or mark steven johnson or
like ue bowl oh did you ever see the
thing out of why you we both does what
he does I hear he's a huge troll he just
likes to screw people up cuz like it's a
hole in the German tax law that because
he puts his own money up for the project
anything he puts into the movie he gets
back so all the profit is pure gravy to
him yeah well they actually they fix
that loophole so like nobody was just to
screw him over cuz i have you noticed
that there have been no more bad video
games movies yeah they stopped coming
out under the ride like house of the
dead i miss you so much for such a great
movie what movie we saw like the first
20 minutes of like this is the worst day
if not one you want to talk about
segways I think I feel about them
finally admitting there's no fantastic
for two yes wall give you people like I
was there to periscope people were
asking about that now was like we'll
just remember guys just because there's
no Fantastic Four to does not mean that
we're not gonna get another shitty
fantastic right here it's just we won't
have to see this horrible series meeting
so I knew this was gonna happen a few
weeks ago cuz i was at foxs UK office a
few weeks ago and they showed us
trailers and scripts and stuff for all
of the upcoming comic book and superhero
movies and it was great I got to see
some stuff that no one else in the world
is senior and and there was no mention
of Fantastic Four to whatsoever and
that I think I think I know what this
means I think uh like I was almost clear
scoping earlier sound like I told me
well I was like you had the best pitch
where likes to post credits reveal of
the Fantastic Four I told him what it
was all so I just have a guy typing and
the cameras pans out there like he does
reaches for some yeah it's just him and
then he's top of the climb are they
gonna be dicks and just hold on to it I
think they'd have to make another
fantastic full movie within the next
five years otherwise the rights
automatically go back into marble that
it's it's so many years it has to be
produced and released in theaters by
that some of your deadline yes yes but
but here's the thing though like
spider-man marvel wanted back he's there
one of their biggest characters but Sony
was willing to play ball and they had
egg on their face after the email
hacking it's still a lot worse between
Fox and Disney at this point and
honestly like Fox I don't think wants to
play that ball and Disney and Marvel
have no interest in getting to back
anyway oh and I just agreed no I
disagree i think that if Marvel got the
wife could you imagine a fantastic for
film by novelty i had heard like it'd be
amazing no i want that like but i really
want the villains back they want the
Galactus the dog would doom the Silver
Surfer they want all those guys back I
think they want a fantastic full rights
back not necessarily for the Fantastic
Four but formally do so because it's the
notice that in humans movie always gets
pushed back at this in any opportunity I
don't fires and all that other ski that
in humans movies just a wait and see
maybe Fox will screw up everything like
that legitimately is I think cuz I
guarantee you let's say Fox says like a
screw it just makes a deal I guarantee
you that in humans we just disappears
now the thing that it always got in the
thing I don't know they're doing a girly
good job with the new inhumans long they
are you know I Ching it and they put all
they put everything they have behind it
like to putting all their money all
their effort like all their talent
behind it they're pushing everything
they can behind this this this one thing
but I think they all know that if they
get those mutants back that makes bank
more like that's just a that's a no
brain and anyone tested are all totally
happy to just just just shove everything
off the table and then just put their
exponential you can continue boy here's
my question for you though
here's my question for that though do
you think they want all the x-men are
they just looking to try and get like
Wolverine back I mean a pullback I think
if they if they could make a deal where
they could just get Wolverine Deadpool
they take it yeah but see I think yeah
it would be stupid for them to get
Wolverine back because who's still like
I know people would go and watch the
movie but genuinely like from Marvel's
perspective they've admitted this in the
comics no one gives a [ __ ] anymore like
kill Wolverine off let that character s
because we know too much about him now
he's supposed to be a character that you
don't know much about what they'll do
the period piece where Wolverine and
Captain America fight it in World War 2
the tail you were never told no but no I
agree on that one foul side one hundred
percent agree because all the people
that are freaking out like the drug cool
farina x-23 my biggest argument is look
I am probably one of the biggest
Wolverine fans I love that character but
the problem with Wolverine I stopped
reading his books I read everything and
I stopped reading it because they
weren't telling anything worth it
anymore there was me old man Logan now
so come one of the last stories that was
viable at he went into the swamps fought
a redneck family that was trying to hack
into his brain and you're like you know
they've run out of ideas in a similar
story all the time like when people
asking about Wolverine I'm like if you
really want to know like how bad
Wolverine stories got like go read Civil
War cuz i tell people like the entire
subplot of over enough was he went to go
find the company they gave a mutant some
kind of like a mutant growth hormone and
that was that was his story it was like
the most haunting down nitro and then
finding out how that worked out like he
had the dot hope I guess yes Emily
bloodhound taking Wolverine out of the
big story and giving him his own story
is a cool notion but unfortunately they
never really give it the attention or
the like just the work it needs like
they think it's so they think it writes
itself and the fact is it doesn't like
Wolverine has been encased in an
adamantium husk for what two years
someone and and no one cared break that
Wolverines 19 Rihanna the end of
Oberon's every Wolverines I read the
first five issues of walgreens and then
like the alien Wolverine came down
should i want to fight and play and I'm
just like
um them so now the problem with like you
sets out that's the best example I I
don't think death the Wolverine even
sold that well like they don't know the
first the first issue sold like hotcakes
first year 100,000 sales buns of
variance yeah what the yes I like that's
good too and it was and it was Charles
soul and Steve McNiven though the book
looked wonderful while oh no you know if
if the book sold well from start to
finish we would have had a book called
Wolverine afterlife and it would have
been about him in death yeah yeah really
this is what I tell everyone that's
freaking the hell out about the new
female reading the new female for the
miss marble taking the title of miss
marble the fact the matter is you just
said it best Faust if the original books
actually sold which meant they had
viable stories they would never would
have changed anything no Thor would
never have passes hammer on if people
had read Godhead in God bomb and those
were still good and it still let's say
they won't change them back in time for
the movies in fact they probably will
yes this little people all the time like
I mean people are you know they get so
cable no Carol Danvers is Miss my well
then name me one volume of her series
that lasted more than like exactly
exactly avoiding the whatever everyone
likes to be like oh no Steve Rogers is
my captain america okay what was the
last story arc that Steve Rogers was in
that didn't happen America Casimir
eboard when he came back does anyone has
anyone else aware that the last major
story arc with Captain America that I
even remember he had like this villain
in his stomach and he was walking around
with them and they were talking and we
had a Kuato is what he had yeah like the
last major story story arc I read was
was obviously like when he when he lost
his healing factor just because I was
curious before that he was not away Joe
like before that I read like the death
of Captain America it was the only one
that I cared about generate I hadn't
read anything I'd even read when he came
back I was like well he's back the facts
of better issues he makes other people
saw them in the movies they saw thor in
the movie they've seen captain america
and now a lot of new fans have said
those are my heroes well don't worry the
Cinematic Universe isn't changing you
obviously weren't buying the comic books
otherwise they wouldn't have changed
those yeah I always say that like if you
call yourself a comic fan but don't buy
the car
Mike's then complain what's in the
comics stop cuz comics clearly aren't
like you that happened I swear whenever
my mighty for number one review goes up
it goes out to all those people and they
all come and want to talk to me do that
some that drives me nuts man like I
posted the playlist for Adam Brashear
like you know Marvel's first black
superheroes what it's called posted that
on reddit something was like no it's
actually Black Panther I did you watch
the video yeah that's like if you watch
the video like it tells you that this
character was a retcon that came before
it look like I say that in the first
five minutes but they didn't they didn't
watch it yeah it's like it's like when I
made the video with the voices and
deadpool's head and the first 45 seconds
I comment around about that the logical
voice is actually thought to be dr. pong
but we have no definitive proof it was
just from the professor and like this
half the comments are what about the
logical voice yeah I caught that how
many people cared about dr. bong is
about the conch count how many times
when they talk about the Judas contract
people like why did you leave out the
part when Tara fell in love with Beast
Boy because she didn't haha or how about
how about this is my favorite one and I
know Rob probably it's the same he's
that crap is me on this one um when you
do civil war and they go I thought this
is the one where Captain America died no
just wait he doesn't die in that book
like we know that because at the final
issue of civil war he didn't die look
exactly the way it was when we know that
you're wrong because if you see the
panel I put up here he's being hauled
away by the yes and they create an event
called the initiative and the death of
Captain America was not called Civil War
the death of Captain America just call
the death of Captain America definitely
dream or whatever you want to call him
rights to write it was it was a really
good story yeah it was it was then that
whole run is a great run from beginning
to his dad dabdoub a hurry every bigger
maybe hit the nail on the head and then
going off of this going off at this
point the comics do affect the movies in
the sense that lots of people saying why
isn't the Carol Danvers movie being
called ms marvel and stow captain model
because the mesmo comics never sold in
Captain Marvel is always sold well yeah
she's a captain damage that just that
just makes good sense like why would you
release a movie called
you know Captain Marvel about Carol
Danvers and then like not called her
captain marvel in the context well like
if they called like ms marvel in the
movie in the movie was called in his
marvel that was why I was saying people
want the movie to be called miss model
yeah well to me just it just makes its
to me I also find it funny that it's
like it's I almost feel like the people
that are upset because she went from
miss marble to camp tomorrow just don't
want to see her progress in the military
yeah well multiple times what they've
actually said captain america and
Captain Marvel are actually captain rank
and anybody who knows the military knows
that is not a high-ranking title see I'm
a big fan of Brigadier General myself I
think that is sounding times we know we
have turtle America that makes sense
yeah I know he was currently rented
zombies what of a general America every
messenger about hear about Captain
Crunch he got knocked down to chief
petty officer credit no like that's
that's just like there was something
which cracked me up because it's like I
don't know I mean well anyway I'm not
wrong but I don't know I don't know no
it's weird to me because Carol Danvers
to me was always like a good background
character I mean I guess they're making
her I won't the point that like we're
also gonna John when I when I was
talking about like prominent female
characters it was like when people think
of like like the female character and
while what comics like they either think
of like miss marble Carol Danvers when
they think of storm look they're like
yes those are the most popular one the
most popular ones exactly they're only
that populate carol danvers was never
popular there was only that they were
like there's only that Marvel finally
around Civil War was like you know we
don't have a Wonder Woman analog nobody
I can i why didn't they could do was was
she hulk like shield was probably the
most pop was one of the biggest most
popular female Marvel characters outside
of the x-men and and she was Green when
she's never look I mean not really but
like non comic readers like she-hulk I
know that that's that every time I say
she helped people like really I know
they always cringe but like if you read
her stories they're great
like no she's really cool and I like but
it really sounds dumb nobody is that
shiner is waiting for the wicked you can
say right now while they're trying all
this stuff out that yeah i agree today
they're trying to get the proper analog
stuff like that going on but they're
trying out new heroes is simply for the
movies who can they make his pop because
if they can make iron man popular
because of the movies because anybody's
been reading comics knows he was not a
popular character he wasn't he was a
recognizable character he was a c-list
at best yeah be fair he would see me I
think it wasn't me but i mean i'll even
go as far as to say captain america
wasn't that popular either simile
because he was Captain America not
gassin it y know it was very shrinkage
which kept the ISIS ill he wasn't a
mutant or a spider so he didn't sell
great but he was always at the front of
the line but I mean everyone likes to be
like oh the Avengers they're the big a
listers amor no they weren't they
weren't found all as it was literally Oh
what really knew about and turned them
into movies and they did well so that's
what they're trying to do again well
years have made been popular they were
known because of what's it like because
they were on the Avengers that's why
they were known like people were like
iron man he's one of the Avengers right
like us know that that's literally what
made them hoppers because they were on a
team you know I mean spider-man's silver
I guess Iron Man solo series like he had
great runs at his involvement with the
Avengers is what kept him popular and
fresh in the minds of people which is
why they bought his story and the
Avengers has always kind of been like
ooh ooh can we Kabul a team out so we
don't have to write a bunch of oranges
who we got sitting around in to back dad
Jack but that was Wonder Man and then
the same things but the same has been
true of like various mutant characters
through the years like you don't need to
think of an origin you can just say
they're a mutant and the powers awakened
that pretty bad headaches oh my god
powers Xavier school yeah well they
sizzle that's that's the whole thing is
like imagine if you would if they had
like taking Tony Stark out of the
Avengers in like the 1980s like 1985
they just took him off the Avengers
roster yeah and he was never on the
Avengers again I guarantee as comics
would have completely tanked and model
would have just cancelled yeah probably
I don't know I wouldn't say I never I'll
tell you this I never read either of
those titles back in the day yeah I was
really likes men I was not reading
invisible but
but the point what I'm saying though is
like Miss marbella them they were like D
and E list you know like they didn't do
anything maybe literally popped up as oh
look it's miss marble she's gonna team
up with spider-man you know she was and
what what they're trying to do Alec yeah
they're trying to make the new CDC and V
Lister's the people who might have a
hope and a movie so like to put this in
like more pop culture perspective or the
people here that don't actually read
comics it's like them telling us we're
gonna get a movie about Kylie Minogue
and they do about Danny no I mean it's
okay like Jessica Jones is a perfect
example we can kind of segue into our
last hop it before we bring a light jazz
to an end but I was gonna x try and
bring it there good good going Rob but
uh but jessica jones is the same way
like the jessica jones netflix series
comes out people watch it and they're
like oh my god that's good in some yeah
jessica jones was popular but makes me
wonder well they tried up her profile in
the all new homes jessica jones the only
way to do that now is because they
didn't know if the show is gonna be a
huge hit yeah yeah but it's a fact that
matter is a jessica jones she had she
was the epitome of a background
character would like she had one book
and ever since then she has literally
done nothing but held luke cage's baby I
mean I'm sure we don't come polls know
every major event she was like upward
we're going away my baby my family
semantics accident remember back in yet
in Civil War when she just literally
peaced out to Canada for the entire man
hung out with me it was great like a
star showed up at their house so he was
like Luke Cage will you find on my side
he's like no man cuz this is like
slavery and then likely k july or iron
man left and lou caves like you need to
go to Canada like I'm let you know by
Captain America ok she was like why
don't you come with me Canada needs
heroes have you ever heard of a Canadian
here like to think I'm a Canadian hero
in my own way okay so I told you all
about this like when I made my videos on
on panels forces Deadpool like I gave I
did like a shout out to the Canadians I
was like I was like Thanos is basically
pissed off because of like of all the
people who give you turned down for one
he was turned down for Deadpool into he
was turned down for a Canadian yeah but
no like you know this this that's the
thing like like jessica jones and i
guarantee you it'll be the same thing
with Danny ran with iron fist oh yeah
same thing like people are like
already getting new Heroes for Hire bomb
yeah oh we're getting luke cage yeah
Luke ages even have a book yeah like
they canceled his but likewise what he
had was an IT something in it last 29
now right oh yeah bummer man I could
have sworn that I Heroes for Hire the
2000s the hat is I'm talking about like
allocate solo series engage and they
canceled it hit him an iron fist have
been together forever now I'd iron fist
we got his own books again he did it
didn't last long another bring them back
together for a guy that's so long good
know the Carrie Andrews run was amazing
it kind of turned me off right away I'm
like oh man this isn't the Danny that I
like you know from the older one but
everything that Susan like more action
years it's so fun I didn't vote for this
Danny he's not my Danny R and not like
everyone tweet that out hashtags your
iron fist not my iron I know like it so
that's this thing this the the funny
thing is is people sit down these like
people ask me like what should I read to
get ready for for Jessica Julius yeah
double the boot yeah like the the trade
paperback where's the meeting although I
only know what happens there you go no
limits chat is a bunch of people in the
chat on your end Rob basically being
like no calf dies a civil war no he does
it for the record Katniss civil war
completely resolves with capital I've
cap dies in the aftermath it's naughty
it's not even like Civil War it's
literally like him dealing with what he
did and then somebody takes a shot
nearly on his way to the trial for the
stuff that happened after that it is not
in civil war it's a series called death
of Captain America I have a shop I will
dig it out right now he's legitimately
just arrested and then leaves and then
iron man smiles for the camera end of
book that's the end of civil sorry
that's it yes the solution should i use
my shell display oh you could say yes he
died because of what happened in civil
war but it's not in silver well early
not only did he not die in civil war
they hadn't have been called in the
initiative that took place between civil
war and the death of Captain America
yeah now dead captain america does
appear in civil war labeled books like
civil war the confessional Tony Stark
talks to his corpse for a whole issue
but like he you know but those aren't
the court that's not the
book the core book is that the death of
Captain America damsel mandrel went to
the presence I went to the press is cuz
i can't i can't believe that people are
actually saying that cuz like i can
literally prove it cuz i got the book
right here I just loved the comments
like that cuz I get them all the time on
my civil war video it's broken a million
views and I get all these people being
like didn't cap dying here no one hears
the blood I could do death of Captain
America right I don't store can America
diary so why don't we didn't because I
do know the entire series but no matter
what we talk about we're gonna have
people saying dumb stuff like that
especially if the characters have been
adapted into a TV show no Raven doesn't
say Azarath metrion zinthos I say in my
sleep but it's cool though yes it's a
later area Raven just an emo girl with
no actual issues and she's got a crush
on Robin oh my god you just broke those
Benny I hope you're happy that way
online corny according to what I've
learned from Teen Titans go I mean
that's all I know sayings is weird al is
gonna play dark side on that show though
i'm julie r ey well yeah whoa which is
like well since that show such [ __ ]
anyway who cares like that sounds like
fun an apocalyptic paradise yeah we're
all crazy new gods and ain't that nice
no like all I know like the only thing I
ever knew from Raven was like Teen
Titans ago that's all I knew about her
characters I'm like man this character
sucks she's supposed to be like an
avatar for depression and how like that
she's the fit almost like the physical
manifestation in the DC Universe about
of how depression affects the human mind
is like it she's like a really good
character and every adaptation about
doesn't [ __ ] get that you know sheshe
kick-started a lot of young men's a
fetish for goth girl so you know hey
let's doesn't know what the new 52
version doesn't rave and have feathers
over her eyes I hope that source so
she's going feather for there's over
yeah look up Aditya Raven I'm gonna do
that right now you are going to hate it
I assure you yeah I mean look what about
the injustice Raven that could be
powered immediately in time
but it's not you'll see in the game oh
well the secret seven Raven where she
died straight away so basically they
never do Raven right right she looks
like a giant cockatoo yeah she's
literally the worst haha my blog heard
of terror Raven there's a bit in the
newer Teen Titans where she like goes
like a goth concert like a Depeche Mode
constant like I love you so much RAM and
you're so dark and tortured just like I
see my comeback stage they takes a drag
off his cigarette looks at his feet is
like the worst part was sorry we've gone
off of topping so much but the worst
part about this run of the Teen Titans
it's just that but it the story just
doesn't end but it's still not over it's
like I just I've never in the entire
history of me reading comics have wanted
a story to end so much because it's in
its teens now and it's showing no sign
of finishing a Titan sounds pretty cool
Oh time just kind of cool again last
question from Faust last question for us
so Starfire is not actually a ditzy girl
that that has no sexuality at all and a
no understanding of anything and it's
usually literally Starfire and the New
Teen Titans was seen sharing a bed with
Dick Grayson back in the 80s that was as
good as Starfire was having sex with her
took them were like 16 at the time no
one cared because that's who stopped by
a she's a really sexual character oh my
god but what about her new outfits where
she doesn't show any real skin and she's
just she's really did see and I mean I
Sun like the new store fire debris I put
pop all marathi and Connor they're funny
they're working the same stuff on that
they were working on Harley Quinn I like
it but it's not Starfire at all like
battle that is like it i know i will
agree the one that work he's custard i
will agree to now a nice exact same
argument is lobo like everyone's like
it's not low but no it's not your logo
this is a different local and they
should have renamed him but it's a good
book in itself it's just a story yeah
cool story bro yeah i thought i think
the new logo Joey's really neat man oh I
like the new story like the direction
that he should be called something
completely cancelled
something about years yeah who's near
the differences Starfire had already
been introduced in this universe as a
sexual character Lobo rhythm of that one
yeah Lobo hadn't and so it the only had
already review old mobo and yeah here's
an honest question for you faster maybe
you can you can answer this one for me
the new ditzy Starfire is this supposed
to be taking place prior to red hooded
me outlaws I always after can I did yeah
I think it's odd that so so she just got
dumb like hit her head well she just got
up and then suddenly she doesn't know
how anything works enough even though
she's been there for like two years if
you had the dcu preview issue which they
released for free online and you could
read them it's her literally going to a
travel office like saying goodbye to Roy
and Jason then Jack she hangs out with
Superman's like well where should I live
Superman yo you're kind of an alien like
me and everything you know you would
understands like well I'm not gonna tell
you to move to Kansas cuz you know that
would that be boring but you know
Miami's cool oh yeah i mean i never
understood all he will got something out
of shape over like changes and
characters i mean i understand why
because they get attached to it but like
like it's a it's a color book creation
I'm fine of changes in attracted labor
day huh I haven't complained like that
they've changed Raven like I i say i
prefer the 1985 Raven but i haven't
complained that she's different in the
new 52 it's whatever but when staff i
had already been introduced as one way
in the new 52 then suddenly over the
course of like less than a month she's
totally gone harlequin did the same
thing harley quinn came out one way
where she was like a Suicide Squad dark
and gritty working with the Joker the
whole nine yards although the new 52 she
was trying to break away from that but
she was still talking Rudy and now she's
like Deadpool is hominy booklets because
it gel with her Suicide Squad appearance
but whatever cuz it sells weed almost
like she walks in she walks into hobo
she's like hey everybody and then like
come over to the Suicide Squad hey
everybody you can literally it's
literally that its litter okay here's
here's a really good point like you know
like Wally West all right I made the
video about the new 52 Wally West and
like ninety percent of the comments
we're just like this Wally West sucks
like well why is that why what's up
because it's not the one that I'm used
to ok and this means it's not when
you're used yeah I mean you know
different is me insane comic redheads
and we were I was just looking at how
awesome is sin isn't sin a cool
character is breathe through this now
man when she gets dressed up in that
shield uniform that's that's that that's
good times what that is okay I'm done oh
that's a great segue to the end of this
podcast right yeah you know it's time to
end the show and Joel just looking
through Tom's man that's a cool panel in
that cool panel but we're gonna be
bringing the show to a close so Alliance
I'm just ditched quick opinions and
jessica jones i don't yeah it was good
two episodes tend to finishing it lots
to like it super could watch it everyone
for next week's podcast chasing his way
better than daredevil so if you were
kind of turned off by the pacing and
daredevil I say give jessica jones or
shot you'll probably like it more I wish
powerful man was purple he's not I was
actually this one these purple in the
trip out scenes is what he is and the
whole show is cast in a purple tint is I
mean you know yeah so anyway I'm Benny
the comic story and that is cell from
comic pop Joel from the Cape Joel a brob
from comics explain were on that channel
and a foul from it's super effective and
just because everyone told me rob liked
it I'm gonna say the ultimate sucked
even though I haven't read it thank you
everybody and will be here next week
same bat Tana back same damn that tail
think that dumb haha thanks woody
woodpecker Benny anyway we're gonna pass
out of here guys